what i want to do in this video is to
show that if we start with any arbitrary
triangle this will be the arbitrary
triangle that we're starting with that
we can always make this the medial
triangle of a larger triangle when we
say the medial triangle we mean that
each of the vertices of these tr of this
triangle will be the midpoint of the
sides of a larger triangle i want to
show that you can always construct that
if you start with this triangle you can
always have this be the medial triangle
of a larger triangle so to do that
let's draw a line that goes through this
point right over here but that's
parallel to this line down here so this
line and this line up here are going to
be parallel so just like that and
immediately we can start to say some
interesting things about the angles so
if we have a transversal right over here
we could view this side as a transversal
of these two parallel lines or this line
in the segment we know that alternate
interior angles are congruent so that
angle is going to be congruent to that
angle and we also know that this angle
in blue is going to be congruent to that
angle right over there now let's do that
for the other two sides
so let's create
let's create a line that is parallel to
this side of the triangle but that goes
through this point right over here
so let me draw
it as well as possible
and so these two characters are going to
be parallel and you can always construct
a line that's parallel to another line
that that goes to a point that's not on
that line and so once again we can use
alternate interior angles we know that
if this angle right over here this let's
say we have this orange angle its
alternate interior angle is this angle
right over there we also have
corresponding angles this blue angle
corresponds to this angle right over
here
so it'll correspond to that angle right
over there and now let's draw another
line that is parallel to this line right
over here parallel to this one right
over here but it goes through this
vertex goes to the vertex that's
opposite that line
and so
let me just draw and you can always
construct these parallel lines
just like that and let's see what
happens so once again these two lines
are parallel so you could view this
green line as a transversal if this
green line is a transversal this
corresponding angle is this angle right
over here
if we view if we view this green line as
a transversal of both of these pink
lines
then this angle corresponds to this
angle right over here
if we view this yellow line as a
transversal of both of these pink lines
actually let's look at let's look at
this way view the pink line as a
transversal of these two yellow lines
then we know that this angle corresponds
to this angle right over here
and if you view this yellow line as a
transversal of these two pink lines then
this angle corresponds to
this angle
right over here
and then the last thing we would have to
the last thing we should we need to
think about
is
if we think about the two green parallel
lines the two green parallel lines and
you look at the and you view this yellow
line as a transversal then this
corresponding angle in orange is right
over here
this corresponds to that angle because
this yellow line is a transversal on
both of these green lines
so what i've just shown
starting with this inner triangle right
over here is that if i construct these
parallel lines in this way that i now
have
four triangles if i include the original
one and they're all going to be similar
to each other and we know that they're
all similar because they all have the
exact same angles you just need two
angles to prove similarity but all four
of these triangles have the exact three
angles now the other thing we can show
is that they're congruent so all of
these four are similar and we also know
they're congruent for example
this side right over here in yellow is
the side and this triangle between the
orange and the green side it's the side
between the orange and the green side on
this triangle right over here so these
two
we have an angle a side and an angle
angle side angle congruency so these two
are going to be congruent to each other
then over here
the on this inner triangle our original
triangle the side that's between the
orange and the blue side
is going to be congruent to the sides
between the orange and the blue side on
that triangle once again we have angle
side angle congruency so this is
congruent to this which is congruent to
that all of these are going to be
congruent
and by the same exact argument
same exact argument this middle triangle
is going to be congruent to this bottom
triangle the you have an angle blue
angle purple side green angle blue angle
purple side green angle they're
congruent to each other so if all of
these triangles are congruent to each
other so their corresponding sides are
equal so if you look at
this triangle over here we know that the
side between the blue angle between the
blue angle and the green angle
is is going to be equal to this angle
right over here i'm sorry it is equal to
this length so it's going to be equal to
this length between the blue and the
green we have this length between the
blue and the green we have that length
between the blue and the green we have
that length right over there so you
immediately see that this point and let
me label it now maybe i should have
labeled it before if we call that point
a we see that a is the midpoint of
of let's call this point b
and call this point c right over here so
a is the midpoint of b c
so that's fair enough so i was able to
construct it in that way now let's look
at the other sides so this green side on
all the triangles is a is the side
between the blue and the orange angle so
between the blue and the orange angle
you have the green side between the blue
and the orange angle you have the green
side so once again this length is equal
to this length and so if we call this
point over here d and maybe this point
over here e you see that d is the
midpoint of b e
and then finally
the yellow side is between the green and
the orange so between the green and the
orange we have a yellow side between the
green the orange you have a yellow side
all of these triangles are congruent so
once again let me call this f we see
that f
is the midpoint of ec so we've done what
we wanted to do we've shown that if you
start with any arbitrary triangle
triangle adf
we can construct a triangle bce
we can construct
construct a triangle b
c e
so
that
adf
a d f
is triangle bce's triangle bce's medial
triangle and all that means all that
means is that the vertices of adf sit on
the midpoints of bce so you might say
sal that by itself is interesting but
what's the whole point of this the whole
point of this is actually i wanted to
use this fact that if you give me any
triangle i can make it the medial
triangle of a larger one to prove that
the altitudes of this triangle are
concurrent
and to see that let me first draw the
altitudes so an altitude from vertex a
looks like this
it starts at the vertex goes to the
opposite side and is perpendicular to
the opposite side
if i draw an altitude from vertex d it
would look like this and if i draw an
altitude from vertex f it will look like
this
and what i did this whole setup of this
video is to show to prove that these
will always
to prove that these will always be
concurrent and you might say wait how do
how do we know that they are concurrent
well all you have to do is think about
how they interact with the larger
triangle how do these altitudes what are
these altitudes to the larger triangle
well this yellow altitude to the larger
triangle
remember these two yellow lines line a d
and line c e are parallel so if this is
a 90 degree angle so it's its core its
alternate interior angle is also going
to be 90 degrees so this right over here
is perpendicular to ce and it bisects ce
because we know that ade is the medial
triangle this is the midpoint so this
right over here is perpendicular
bisector this is a perpendicular
bisector bisector for the larger
triangle for triangle b
c e so this altitude for the smaller one
is a perpendicular bisector for the
larger one we can do that for all of
them
if this angle right over here is 90
degrees then this angle right over there
is going to be 90 degrees because this
line is parallel to this this is a
transversal alternate interior angles
are the same
so this line right over here this
altitude of the smaller triangle it
bisects right at the midpoint of the
larger one on this side and it's also a
perpendicular bisector so it's a
perpendicular bisector of the larger
triangle and then finally the same thing
is true of this altitude right over here
it bisects this side of the larger
triangle
at a 90 degree angle we know that
because these two magenta lines the way
we constructed the larger triangle
they're going to be parallel so once
again this is a perpendicular bisector
so this whole reason if you give me any
any triangle i can take its altitudes
and i know that its altitudes are going
to intersect in one point they're going
to be concurrent because for any
triangle i can make it the medial
triangle of a larger one and then its
altitudes will be the perpendicular
bisector for the larger triangle and we
already know that the perpendicular
bisectors for any triangle are
concurrent they do intersect in exactly
in exactly one point